the stories that are most interesting
are the stories that power and money
don't want told
that when um the stories and i'm
competitive about it
when somebody rich and powerful says you
shut up
all the trouble that's what gets me out
of bed and
or gets me out of the pub in the evening
because i wanna
i wanna i wanna tell those stories
and and and and so i kind
of i would always think of myself more
of a storyteller
who's ended up telling stories powerful
people don't want told
than an investigative journalist vessel
journalist has got too many syllables in
it and it sounds a bit high and mighty
but i'm a storyteller and really i kind
of i just want to be in the
in bed or in the pub but the moment
somebody said you shut up
the church of scientology says the
former
members you shut up all the north korean
secret police
you know say um create this
bizarre fantasy of what their dark
tyranny is
that kind of gets me going and then off
i go
what is your view then i know you have a
a long history working with institutions
like the bbc
and more um you know very large
media institutions in the uk what what
is your view right now
on the current state of media and
technology and social media being a
journalist
well um by the way the the thing i
forgot to mention
uh which i should do listeners is um
viewers is that i'm also a writer um and
the other day
so i've written 12 books eight
non-fiction one about scientology one
about north korea
four novels um
one of them the latest whatever let me
find it here we go
um is the youthful idiot
which is probably reads upside down but
anyway you get a drift
and that's about stalinism and fake news
in 1933
and really it's a story of two reporters
in 1933 in moscow
one of them was walter durrante who
worked for the new york times originally
from liverpool an englishman
who ended up working for the new york
times and he for example got a great
scoop where he managed
to interview stalin but of course you
don't get to interview stalin
unless you play goody two-shoes and what
walter durrante did
was he told a great lie which was
there was no famine in the soviet union
in 33
and there was and maybe as many as seven
seven million people died now this is
fake news back in
33 and there was another reporter
called gareth jones and he told the
truth about the famine
and he was shot dead in china
two years later than 35 i believe by the
nkvd which who then become the kgb
those are the people the secret police
that vladimir putin worked for they're
now called
the fsb same old [ __ ] i would say
so the problem of
of misinformation of lies the big big
lies
that's not new there's a great french
writer gustav lauber who once said our
ignorance of history makes us
slander our own times things have always
been like this
and that's kind of true or rather that's
very true
but nevertheless i found
the rise and rise of social media and
the
and the wild west nature of it scary
and troubling um i'm not a trumpist
or whatever you call him the former guy
as joe biden calls him but i
i thought that there is a kind of
unhorsing of reason
and logic and and respect for facts
that have gone up that have
ridden along with the the rise and rise
of social media
and that's become frightening and as i
said my introduction
a bit in last um 2019
i tried to do this story about tommy
robinson the far-right guy in britain
and i got clobbered on social media
um by his supporters so much so that
effectively i've
i have a presence on facebook but it's
very minimal and it's not active
i do um uh i'm on twitter a lot
at john sweeney raw r o a r
they've gone away uh from my life
um most of the time but the reason they
did that was that
what happened was that we had a good
investigation into tommy robinson him
um telling a bunch of the german far
right in bavaria
um for too long the german people have
lived
under the guilt of adolf hitler now you
don't say that
that's a foolish thing to say it's a
dangerous thing to say
in particular to that german far-right
audience
in bavaria don't do that
the bbc didn't run our film and so all
that happened was i kept on getting
death threats and being threatened and
being humiliated
and i wasn't allowed by my big
organization to fight back
it was really really difficult
eventually i left
the moment i left i put up a video in
which like
i'm going to swear now is what's your
policy
as much as you want okay well i said um
i'll give you the piece of camera in my
view and these are not the views of the
bbc
tommy robinson you're a nazi [ __ ]
cheers cheers
now the benefit of that this is i'm
drinking italian red
you by the way you will not
this is a beautiful wine from italy
you're drinking something disgusting
terrible and that's not and that's why
i worry about american civilization yeah
it's either this or jack daniels
the uh yeah i mean that's okay um
as a kind of tranquilizer
but this is nice anyway never mind that
um still being a wine
the it was horrible being attacked on
social media in this way
the moment i put that video out and it's
got something like um
did it on twitter two minutes and it's
got something
like half a million views or more the
heat
went from tommy robinson's supporters
because
these people can smell fear
and i wanted it was a simple message i'm
not afraid of you
and i had the clip of robinson in
germany talking about adolf hitler
in the way that he did in the film
and and so that um the pressure
from that crazy
far-right community went away because
they could tell
that actually it wasn't me who was
afraid of them it was my bosses at the
bbc
but i fundamentally do not believe that
people
um i when i post stuff on twitter
everybody knows it's me i am john
sweeney raw i am me
and i don't think anonymity causes
is a thing for good because it means
that i mean i know there are various
arguments for it but essentially
it means that you can get a pylon from
people who can behave dreadfully
because they're doing it behind a
curtain we don't know who they are
and i don't think that's good i don't
think it's good for the public square i
don't think it's good for
for democracy or the rule of law and
some of these people
aren't american or british they're
russian you know the russian bots now we
know this
or they're chinese and they can be north
korean or they can be anybody i don't
know who they
are so um i
you know that's a problem um now weirdly
i think that covid has helped to reset
some of that balance i do think that
2016 was a poison year
and what's happened with covid is we get
it
that society matters that working
with others matters that some of the
lowest paid
people in our societies have been the um
um i've been the best of us i'm talking
about the you know the
amazon delivery people my bin men
who i just these days when they empty my
bins
and i say thank you all of that stuff um
i'm a londoner that's kind of new
civility
so there's something so there was a big
anxiety
in 2016 2017 2018
part of that is my knowledge of
of of the kremlin of what's happening
because i've met putin
of i can see that putin is manipulating
things behind the scenes
and that led me to real disquiet
at the same time i think that um that
joe
joe's got something and in britain we're
still carrying on with brexit i don't
think it's going to work i think it's
a silly mistake to put kind of
nationalism above um the best possible
trade deal you could get
that's my view i also think
that the the media have been to elise's
for too long
and there is and
there isn't a proper correction on that
so at the moment the problem
which the media has created um
in in part for itself they haven't
properly addressed it
um they're addressing some of the
easier things but not some of the other
stuff which is that
if everybody so for example in british
terms
there would be hardly anybody um
where i worked who were who was on
benefit
who who knew family members who were on
benefit
because everybody went to oxbridge and
all that kind of stuff
one of my friends is a guy called owen
phillips who is very
very good who did a fantastic series
um for the bbc about rupert murdoch he's
welsh working class and he feels this
much more passionately than i do
but i had like hardly any friends at the
bbc
who were working class because there
were hardly
any working-class people at the bbc i
kind of sort them out because they're
more fun
and cleverer and smarter because they've
driven
they've risen with nothing very little
i'm going on too much no no no not at
all um